San Francisco I'll be back Friday
December 8th and Saturday December 9th
at Cobbs Comedy Club it's the last stop
of the live and Alive tour for 2023 get
your tickets at
ryanr the honey do with Brian
[Music]
[Applause]
sichler welcome back to the Honeydew
y'all we are over here doing it in the
night pan Studios I am Ryan sichler Ryan
sickler Ryan sickler on all your social
media I'm going to start this episode
like I start every episode by saying
thank you thank you for supporting this
show thank you for subscribing to this
show I can't thank you all enough for
your support it's wild to me I was just
sitting here talking to our guest about
where comedy is and what how long we've
been doing this and that so I appreciate
you and if you got to have more then you
got to check out the patreon it's called
the Honeydew with y'all and it's this
show with y'all and y'all have the
craziest stories we're I don't know how
many hundreds of episodes in at this
point and no one has stories like you
it's five bucks a month that's it
there's no tears nothing go check it out
and if you're looking for a new podcast
to listen to go listen to my old podcast
it's called The Crab feast and it's uh
it's a podcast I did with Jay Larson and
that Library this year and I want to say
thank you to the feaster out there that
Library it's been dead for 5 years it
did over a million downloads this year
so it is still thriving out there it's
called the CRA Feast that it's every
comedian you know and love in podcasting
with different stories so go check it
out all right go support my special on
YouTube it's out now as an album um and
also you can now get this show the
Honeydew video on Spotify nothing
changing anywhere else it's just also
you can go watch this on Spotify all
right that's the B you know what we're
doing over here we're highlighting the
low lights and I always say these are
the stories behind the storytellers and
I'm beyond excited to have this guest on
here today ladies and Gentlemen please
welcome Lewis Black welcome to the
Honeydew leis black thank you Louis
thank you very much for being here it's
my pleasure now you don't even know dude
will you um plug and promote everything
and anything you like you want to pull
that mic a little closer to you you can
pull that closer to you um is that good
yeah you're good test test um got we've
got uh I've got I have a a a rant cast I
it's I we instead of podcast I read I in
a sense do somewhat what you do which is
uh I you as people for the the the
horrible experiences basically I ask
them to yell about whatever it is that
is on their mind and it can be anything
from I've pickles people have gone after
each other for pickles you don't put a
pickle on my plate
it's ejaculating all over my burger I'm
serious it's like what is the matter
with you people I get that you know it's
I don't know why you're what's wrong
with that resona with me why that but
it's true and then there and then there
people writing back that's the best part
of the plate you know they go nuts on
each other and one a guy opens a can of
uh a jar of peanut butter and it's
supposed to be and I can't even remember
if it was crunchy or smooth I think it
was supposed to be smooth and it was
crunch
and he literally a 7even minute write I
mean the thing is is they write this out
oh so you're getting this oh I'm reading
it I'm reading seven minutes on on the
level of the the amount that he hates
you know uh that uh that he he wanted he
was supposed to be smooth and he ended
up with this this crunchy crap so I kind
of do that that's on uh you know that's
on Apple and all wherever you get these
things a friend of mine I want I don't
mean to interrupt you but he actually
sent a few of these in uh his name is
James Reinhardt what's up big game James
and this a couple years ago I want to
say he sent these in and you chose I
think a couple a few of his I think at
Le at least two it might have been three
that the name's really James Reinhardt
yeah and I was like you trying to tell
me you're writing for Lou black on the
side right now you know what the [__]
going on dude yeah so I I knew about you
doing that because he had hit me up like
hey Lewis does this and I was like oh
this is great because it's the both ways
the two things you do one is is that
people don't get it until they hear it
so that it's like you can talk about
what's going on out there but you never
hear the personal sign and you never and
and if something horrible happens to
someone uh and I'm not you know you
basically get some schmuck reporter in
front of them so what did it feel like
did what was that moment you know no let
the person which is what you're doing
you let the person talk the same way in
which I go you know I somebody somebody
has a problem with health insurance you
know you write down what it was they'll
give you a whole list I stood in line
they screwed me this way then they
screwed me that way then they screwed me
and it's and you I think it makes a huge
difference I think it's it's kind of
gives you it gives folks out there a
sense really a more human sense of
what's going on especially in the age
and I bet you find voices out there that
are like oh if just would have applied
yourself into writing or comedy you
definitely would have nailed this Lane
but you're a doctor or whatever am I
right about that what happened was so
many talented people as it as it's moved
along they write they my writing for my
voice is like as I said writing for a
big barking dog it's not difficult it my
voice is very obvious to write for once
they picked up on that the level of the
writing that was coming in has been
astonishing at times it's exactly as you
said that's crazy you you know and then
and then otherwise as long as I'm
plugging my CRA pleas all of it I'm good
I'll be doing shows if you go to ll.com
you'll see all of the list of the shows
I'll be uh I'll be in in two weeks I'll
be in Cleveland and Cincinnati at the at
the uh at the casinos and then I'm going
to um I'll be in Knoxville Tennessee and
uh I'll be wandering around like an
idiot is what I'll be doing and I'm
wandering around for up in through April
and I end April uh I play you'll because
we're from the same area I play the
Kennedy Center which I never played oh
wow do you really yeah you never have
even with the Daily Show and all that
throughout there play I played Warner
because uh the when I was going to do a
special the first people I approached
was the Kennedy Center to do this
special in Washington I wanted to do it
there was all about a bunch of there was
bit of the political in that so it was a
good place to do it and I loved playing
you know as you know it's great to go
back yeah and so I you know so but uh
but the Kennedy said this is like 20
some odd years ago turned it down be
turned me down working there because
they'd seen my HBO special and I said
[__] too much n yes they said they
counted 100 [__] somebody said they
[__] us on a daily basis in this country
and you can't say the word plus it's
this is what YouTube does it's the same
principle one person over there is like
he says [__] too much for who for who he
I don't think he says it enough yeah I
didn't even hear him you know what I
mean I'm not listening for the [__] I'm
listening for the jokes and the laughs
yeah wow really yeah so you so they
bumped it yeah that was the second and
that was really that was an HBO an HBO
special so they're bumping an HBO
special at the Kennedy Center I said the
Kennedy Center the the president who
slept with everybody yeah I mean come on
let's give me a grip come on so I'm I'm
going to be doing that I uh uh and I
guess that really that's uh that's
what's going on now and then if if uh
all goes well with the strike uh at some
point I will probably sit in the Daily
Show I'll be I'll be host you know they
have guest hosts and I just before I'm
I'm basically I'm a union guy so I mean
just before the writer strike which I'm
in that group they they went uh you know
it was I was literally two weeks from
that time I was supposed to be doing The
Daily Show and they went oh we're going
on strike well okay and it it's and uh
and it was good that we went on strike
but now I've got to wait for the you
know until sag after it fires back up
yeah it's coming though yeah it is and
will you get like a week or just
different spots at a time how do they
run three or four days in a row three or
four in a row yeah well look I'm stoked
to have you on here you told me we were
talking before you're 75 I can't even
get over that you look amazing I
definitely would get shot you at 60
that's very kind and this for me is I
didn't tell you this before but this is
a it's a wild turn of events I love life
so this is 25 years in the making for me
when I got here in 1990 well the second
time I got here to California
97 uh I took a job at a hotel called the
Beverly Prescott this is now Lowe's it's
a Pico and
beverwill and you come in the lobby and
I'm here to I haven't even started
comedy yet I haven't even started doing
standup in La yet I had tried it out in
Baltimore at Winchester where you also
performed and um I see you and I'm like
I just leave the front desk I'm like
[__] this and I just take the elevator
up with you I was such a fan and I
didn't know how to even say hello to you
and I was like I don't want to bug him
he looks tired it was later in the
evening I think you had just done a show
somewhere in that area and uh I got in
the elevator with you and you said how
you doing I said I'm good how are you
and you said tired you literally said
tired and I said I'm a big fan I'm here
to do comedy you said work hard and
looks 25 years later you're [__]
sitting in that chair right now that's
wild yeah it is wild so thank you for
being yeah I'm telling you I'm super
stoked to have you here oh thanks yeah
it's it's a pleasure and I'm glad I
didn't say go [__] yourself I wish you
would I wish you
would what if if I can ask you coming
out of Baltimore MH you say you New York
you could choose to go to New York or LA
and and it always interests me what what
what was the why was the choice for La
the winter wow I was sick of living I
don't mind playing in the snow I don't
want to [__] live in it I was tired
of getting up at I would go to talson at
I'd work at UPS shout out to UPS
Baltimore Hub primary one Joe Avenue
till like 300 or 4 in the morning in the
winters in uh in the that Hub and then
I'd sleep for a couple hours I drive to
talson in the morning and I had an a
1990 Honda Civic with original rims and
I would have to pop the [__] hatch to
get in because my doors were frozen and
I just got tired of living like that and
I was like it's either New York or it's
La I also really like the freedom of
driving I like to drive I I went West
that's that was those were the two
factors driving in Winter that's really
it wow that's really it and I don't mind
driving but I did not like the 405
that's not driving got the 101 all of
that nonsense no and and when I first
came out here and this for you espe the
same time frame you know I could drive
the car through these neighborhoods and
now that's gone yeah you ain't doing
that anymore those [__] apps like
ways ruin neighborhoods cuz like well
you can go through this neighborhood to
get there faster now everybody's
shooting through neighborhoods yeah and
then they're making the bumps and then
they're sitting and now that and now
these neighborhoods have cuz that was
really my old apartment building we
couldn't it was because of that there'd
be a line of 12 cars at the stop sign
waiting to get to go because they were
routing them all through there and we
couldn't even get out of our driveway
because everybody's just sitting there a
damn that's really perfect that's a joke
that I would do when I first came out
here I said there will come a point
where you will go and sit in your car
and you turn your car on and you will
not be able to back out of your driveway
because there not of traffic there 100%
Happ I said you'll bring a sandwich and
you'll sit there and finish your lunch
and go back in the house
pull right back go this was a great day
maybe I'll get out
sandwich uh but list I I really do want
to um get to talk to you and know a
little more about you because you're a
Maryland are you Maryland or you DC no
Maryland you are I'm Silver Spring okay
which was literally you know equidistant
between um DC and Balon is that right is
that really the halfway pretty close you
know it it really is in some ways it's
uh Silver Spring is closer but but I
mean but not by to to DC but not not by
much you you know I was 25 minutes or 30
minutes from Baltimore so where um what
was it like growing up do you have
brothers siblings parents my brother I
had a brother uh he passed away sadly uh
he was uh in his in his 40s that you
know cancer kind of sucked what kind of
cancer yeah we don't know because my
mother says they they ask we can do what
an autopsy now my mother's my brother's
getting cremated and I'm and he was a
smoker I was a smoker at that point uh
and I said uh you know we got to see
what it was cuz he had lung issues and
we didn't know if it was lung or Lim
just can we find out because I'd like to
know she goes no we're not gentics
you're genetics no we're not I said come
on I've got to know he's dead and he's
going to be dust he's going to be dust
it's not not like we're we're you know
we're going to bury him and that you
know we're hacking him up no and so I'm
not letting them out a who it's no one's
going at him he's gone please so so I uh
um so he was uh we don't know what it
was ultimately but but we think it was
lung and uh and then I don't know if
you've lost people with the thing that
gets weird over I have the show why I
have the show yeah so uh so you know
what you end up with is uh you know you
you you you wonder you know about these
people that you know that when like my
brother others you go you know three
more years they would have they were
testing a drug on him and I kind of kept
you know that and that didn't work so
but three years later they evolved the
drug and and now you know people who had
whatever cancer my brother had chances
are that because of the the level of the
drug and you just go if they only lived
two more years one more year 6
weeks what so the hospitals weren't able
to tell you or he just didn't go for
treatment at all no it was no he went
for treat we the the hospital wasn't
sure if it was lung or where it started
got it and I just would like to have
known if it's if it started in the
lymphs and got in the lungs but but uh
he uh he passed but uh he was a younger
brother three years younger he he was
the youngest all boys just there were me
and my brother that was now here's the
uh and then my my mother and father my
mother passed away last October she was
104 did she really get to4 yeah she got
to 104 hell yeah was she still with it
and together and I mean as I say uh she
there's a condition she had which uh all
if you're if you if they're not facing
Dementia or Alzheimer's they come up
with what my mother has they'll name the
condition at some point my mother just
made [__]
up
[Music]
just made it all the way to 104 just
making [__] up especially the last four
years she would just tell these stories
I'm go what the
[__] she apparently I mean this people
won't even a younger members of the
audience Maurice chaler was this singer
this French singer and did some films
and stuff and my mother told a whole
story about how she was sitting in the
audience and stood up and told him off
while he was on stage stopped him in the
middle of a song and the audience
brought her on stage and then she
brought me out and that's how my career
started there it is there's the I was
gonna ask what's the Genesis of your
that's my mother that's it's a better
story it's too bad it would have taken
would have taken a lot of the pain
out I wouldn't had to play
Winchesters for
damn that's for damn sure oh but see
that's interesting to me how the mind
works too so she would tell it like it
was true and she's speaking from memory
and all this is just fabricated yeah it
was fabricated what's amazing is to
watch that mind when it's still Lucid in
the sense of you're not you don't have
Alzheimer's you don't have dementia what
you do she know she's creating a story
she's got a through line she's kind of
you know you think well now she's
turning a corner she ain't and then
she'll pick something up and you go God
it it's stunning to listen to so she and
my father lived to 101 damn you have l
so unfortunately your younger brother
but you guys seem to have longevity we
do have longevity I were they either of
them smokers yeah my mother smoked till
she was 65 and and made it to
104 and man yeah and your dad as well I
feel like everybody from that generation
smoked cuz they told you no my dad uh
smoked early on like till he was five or
you know I was five or six he smokes
cigars and then he quit he didn't really
like them and that was that he never
smoked so and he made it to one my
mother really did kind of part of what I
always thought was keeping her going cuz
my father died and uh who died first my
father died first and then you figure
when you've got when they've lived
together that long I thought you know if
she lived six more months that' be
remarkable because mostly they cuz
they've been together like 69 70 know
some 70 71 years and so you kind of go
well how's this how's it going to work
she can't is she uh and um he was just
incredible to watch uh that she had
there was somebody down the hall who was
older than her and she just kept every
so she go I'm going to beat her you know
the woman down the hall she mom's 101
the woman's 103 I'm going to pass her
you know she's going to I'm gonna what
whatever she get that fire well that was
it was really and whenever she had
like uh you know the one of the things
she passed on to me but was anger but
she she was I always felt I hate that
[__] down all that old bit but you
think you know in terms of anger that
she was literally I kept thinking you
know as long as she's got something to
be irate about she's going to keep going
and then uh and then she kind of just
got tired of it and but the 104 and 101
is if you could the they said basically
you would it would be the equivalent of
winning the lottery to have parents live
that long is that right yeah that it
would be parents that are 100 plus and I
in my reaction was sometimes I wish I'd
rather have the
money you know really they could have
lived in 96 I mean
that's yeah really 99 is very
good
that too good I mean it's really kind of
amazing so they were and it was it was
and it was a pretty good group I mean it
was a you know it was a good family you
know they really the tough thing now is
there's nobody you know it's kind of
like do you
remember yeah you're alone huh they're
all gone MH do you remember when your
brother
passed um what that was like for your
parents having to bury a child cuz I
mean and also I know they didn't know
they were going to make it so long but
chances are if you're making it to 100
you're burying your kids most likely
you're burying everybody yeah everybody
well you know that's yeah you know
that's that's the thing you know that
you have you know that you the the
parent is not supposed to outlive the
child so they were how old were they
when your brother passed so
40 they were
uh in their 70s said they were teenagers
yeah said but with that
yeah I told them to move out of the
house well my brother actually let's say
so they were about
81 or uh is where they were 80 8179 or
81 and I once he died and now I'm
touring my ass off and I you know and uh
and I say I go first off I go you uh you
you you're going to have to move uh out
of the house I mean because they're
going to be you know I thinking you know
by by8 yeah and by 83 but you figure but
they were in really good shape and
taking trips my father drove till he was
95 damn really yeah uh and only because
my mother made him drive he didn't like
driving anymore could
see he's you know they shrink
and barely seeing over the steering
wheel for Christ's sake were they did
they stay in Maryland the whole time
they they it was interesting they moved
from they uh they they were in silver
spring and moved sold the house and my
mother looked at everything uh
everything around and found this place
in owing Mills yeah I lived there for a
little bit and uh they moved there and
and they really you know and that was
the reason you know they could still
they could drive back roads they could
go to the places they wanted to go uh
and and you know cuz I said to you this
is another one bik so they I said you
know we've got it there's a place here
in New York right down the block for me
so uh you know this might be where you
and pop want to stay so I take her to
this thing and it's a it's a pretty good
assisted living situation and uh I take
him in there and I take Mom in Dad's not
there and she looks around she comes out
I said what do you think she said here's
what I think if we lived a block from
each other okay within a year one of us
would be dead and it's not going to be
me so and they was good the oh she was
really something and so that was really
you know that then they stayed in Mar
they loved they both liked Maryland a
lot you know you know I miss it I think
it's a great state it's a great it's an
underestimated State it's treated like
oh oh look look Washington DC got a
cancer it's called Maryland [__] you
[__] you is right you got all four
seasons you got an ocean a bay and a
city you got legit mountains the
Appalachian Mountains out there out west
it's yeah it's and you got history and
such history and great history and you
know I mean our country's national
anthem was written in the in Baltimore
was yeah just from yesterday not knowing
I was going to see you if somebody was
talking to me about why would you go to
Baltimore cuz we wrote the starb about
they schmuck every song come on go there
you go to Fort McKenry okay spend a day
there constellation shs there and
then it's funny cuz as a kid we're field
tripping nonstop to the Smithsonian and
the fort mckenny when you're kid you're
like okay big deal then I move out here
and people are like have you ever been
to DC I'm like every [__] Year from
kindergarten to 8th grade I've been to
DC like I've never been I'm like you
never been and then I start realizing
like oh my God no [__] we we drove we're
so lucky then you get up and you see the
fort mchenry's literally built like a
star yeah exactly and then they let you
fold the flag and all that you're like
yeah there's real history real history
and I think and it's I started talking
about it in my ACT not as a joke but
just to tell just to basically inform
them you've never been there you yell
about your government and you never step
foot in the city where it is now get
your ass up and go there because if you
don't like the government that's well go
see you know you don't even know how it
ended up off course go see who who
founded this country and what they don't
go west of the
stadium you might not need to see the
Babe Ruth Museum or the ago Museum but
go definitely during the daytime
yeah um okay so they both live to be
that long they obviously have to bury
your your brother their child but they
but they actually what I did do was and
and this is advice I would give people
because your parents really I mean they
were they you know depression you know
and I I to be honest I didn't have the
depression in part because when he when
I returned he he had I had seen him left
and he when I got home in New York they
called I was taking a Subway home he he
had passed away got back in the subway
went back to see him and see him there
and felt him in the room you did totally
and felt him pretty much for until my
mother died wow and then I how long was
that and then I think she grabbed him
and now she won't let him back you son
of a but she uh but really it was it was
pretty incredible I mean I literally
felt that presence and I'm not like a wo
it I was kind of like this is weird um
and uh and and and but so I took them
aside after about about almost 6 months
a year and said okay um now uh you got
to snap out of it because you know what
I'm here I'm still here you can't ignore
me I you know I need you to you know to
let's stay on point I'm as sad as you
are about this I am not happy um and
we've got to you know we've got to kind
of regroup the wagon and we did you know
and they to their that kind of
relationship with your parents or you
you just said I'm taking this bull by
the horns and I did have we had a pretty
it was it was kind of like one of those
things where sometimes you say [__] and
then you'd say it you know two years
after the fact but this was really like
for me as much but as as much for them
because they were still really mobile I
mean I took them on trips with me we'
you know they'd go if I was working
casinos on the East Coast you know
they'd be at like Mohan Sun they'd come
up there go out to you know Vegas and
stuff I would fly them out you know and
they love that and uh and so uh it it
was kind of like okay it's and now it's
going to be fun cuz I'm doing well okay
you know you know somebody else is
paying for this and do you do you uh did
your brother have a family or kids or
anything wife and that was it they not
they had not had a child no kids yeah so
there was you know that's kind of like
there's no one right no one left in my
mother my parents continuing in the
light of you wanting to know about my
family my parents were born both born
and raised in New York um and came back
to uh moved to
Maryland which is I mean both of them
moved to unusual oh wait they didn't
they met in Maryland no they they no
they met in New York and moved to
Maryland together together and they
moved out of the city because they
wanted to get away from both their
families and they didn't want to deal
with that [__] 4our Drive was enough
for them that was it that's fine we'll
get out and then we and then we would go
back so it was great we' go two three
times a year and then you could see they
were relieved to get out you know it was
uh they had you know some good but they
didn't my they there there were only
certain people in the family that they
liked so in a sense they're just a few
relatives that I have most of most of my
family now are my friends my close
friends um in Maryland though did you
have any extended family or was everyone
all in New York there was a couple uh
here and there and I don't know how they
got there you know but they were they
were they were down in Virginia they
were just in like in ant costy or you
know Alexandria and that was it and
everybody else was up there this holiday
season you might be looking for
nutritious convenient meals to keep you
energized on jam-pack days Factor
America's number one ready to eat meal
delivery service can help you fuel up
fast for breakfast lunch and dinner with
Chef prepared dietitian approved ready
to eat meals delivered straight to your
door you'll save time you'll eat well
and you'll stay on track with your
healthy lifestyle while tracking all of
your holiday to-dos enjoy extra
convenience any time of day with over 45
add-ons to suit various preferences and
taste with Factor you can rest assured
you're making a sustainable choice they
offset 100% of their Del delivery
emissions and Source 100% renewable
electricity for their production sites
and offices this November get factor and
enjoy eating well without the hassle
simply choose your meals and enjoy fresh
flavor pack meals delivered to your door
ready in just two minutes no prep No
Mess head to factor meals.com honeydew
50 and use code honeydew 50 to get 50%
off that's code honeydew 50 at Factor
meals.com honeydew 50 to get 50% off did
you know that traditional
anti-depressants only work for 40 to 60%
of people they can also come with heavy
side effects make you feel numb and may
require taking a daily pill for the rest
of your life we need more and better
Alternatives there's no quick fix for
anxiety and depression but there could
be something to unlock your brain a new
way of thinking about and seeing the
world and maybe that thing is guided k
therapy from mind Bloom there's a new
tool to improve your mental health atome
ketamine therapy mind Bloom is the
leader in atome ketamine therapy having
safely help thousands of people overcome
their anxiety and depression unlike
traditional talk therapy ketamine Works
quickly and doesn't have the unpleasant
side effects of traditional
anti-depressants in a study of over
1,200 mind Bloom clients 89% reported
improvements in their anxiety and
depression after only four sessions
right now mind Bloom is offering my
listeners $100 off your first six
session program when you sign up at mind
bloom.com honeydo and use promo code
honeydew take the first step and break
free from your anxiety and depression
with mindbloom mind bloom.com honeydo
and use promo code honeydew now let's
get back to the D all right so I'm going
to ask you this I'm because I'm hearing
you cough yeah and you're telling me
your brother probably passed oh yeah are
you taking care yourself are you you
seen a pulmonologist oh yeah I'm good
boy yeah don't worry about as a person
who just went through what I went
through with lung clots and everything
I'm hearing you no you got you what
you're hearing is the sound of smoke in
not cigarette smoke from years ago from
years ago but also I have a COPD so I
have an underlying condition but it's
not debilitating it's just here's the
sound of a healthy
animal so
that's and I find if I talk a
lot I get uh flemy unless I'm on stage
no problem how do you deal is it I was
going to say how do you deal with that
in stand up yeah it work you know is
that [__] crazy I I I could have dire
I always before I go up feel like I'm
about to [__] myself I get nerves I know
and all PE I've never had to walk off
the stage to piss no poop nothing no and
you go on and then it's also uh you go
on stage and the energy coming from them
lifts you two feet off the ground and
all of a sudden you're going you know
you kind of go you're a little TI I mean
what what's really weird I know that
it'll be a good show if I'm
yawning I'm sitting backstage and I'm
not tired I'm just like I'm really and I
kind of go boy because people go how do
you rev up for it how do I rev up for it
I walk I take three feet out and they
seem they're happier to see me than I've
ever been to see myself amen you know
yeah people are like don't you need to
get in a zone I'm like no when I walk
out there that's the Zone it's they're
going to Zone it for me yeah I'm going
to be like are you serious yeah I can't
even get over it every time I'm almost I
had a standing ovation and I got
embarrassed I was like you're making me
feel weird it's nice but you're making
me feel weird because you're what you
just said you're way more excited to see
me than I ever have been to see what is
when they do that it's kind of like cuz
what
happens uh I think there's that moment
because I have that thing I mean I I'm
going and also I'm like going it was
okay it's not a standing ovation okay
you know but part of your brain also you
know that whoever you were on stage once
you're done you go since you're not
talking all of a sudden you're back to
being you know Ryan again yeah not Ryan
the stage Ryan you're just Ryan and you
kind of go and once that drops once that
bage drops it's like what's up with you
folks you know like that guy left the
stage okay
you know over like yeah I'm fine yeah um
so tell me about growing up in Maryland
then were you close with your brother
yeah very you guys were how old were you
aart three years three years who and he
was the younger brother he was the
younger brother so he uh he's the one
who really uh was was uh he he did uh he
he was he got on the uh he became the
president of this you know the school he
became oddly enough back then the big
battle was was of then this is irony the
definition of
irony you know this I'm giving it to you
so my brother uh W part of the reason he
wins is the the president uh and he won
it twice in a row which is unusual Ian
he was a good really remarkable kid and
uh he want it because he he pushed for
and got done a smoking Lounge nah-uh
yeah he got it he made it happen he made
it happen listen I've talked about this
on this podcast I was a freshman in 1987
8788 is my freshman year 899 wait 8788
89 yeah n yes freshman year 1987 that's
the last year we had a [__] smoking
lounge and I asked my friends like do
you guys remember that and some of them
do and I'm like it was right on the
corner by the science rooms and it was
this one little room and you had to
either be 18 or your parents had to be
trash and sign a permission slip to say
that my 15-year-old can smoke [__]
cigarettes and it was in the school and
that corner was just like a dragon
belched you know what I mean and then
they stopped it because obviously yeah
and then all the bathrooms were just you
couldn't even go in and take a leak
without coming out and stinking like you
smoke like it was bad it was bad that's
interesting he fought for a smoking L he
fought for a smoking lounge and died of
lung cancer I mean it's just that the
definition of
irony it's just it was weird and he
didn't smoke terrible what do you mean
oh okay yeah he smoked later on he did
that for the people he's a man of the
people yeah but so for me I mean just to
clear up the thing about my my health is
I had uh I had about a pneumonia a while
back and uh and that's this is the
residue I see uh and that was
like December of of last uh last
December so that was really uh what and
that's the sound of the healthy animal
so and so uh so and but it's but I mean
you know then they they I kind of went
through everything D and I'm back to you
know the you know it's just energy level
is not what it used to be yeah you know
but that keeps coming back and that just
takes time you know any other health
scares over the years
no nothing never a crazy kid never
breaking bones or any of that kind of
stuff never broke a no question then and
then he left the podcast don't fall down
our stairs please Jesus Christ I forgot
it was this
high it was Vertigo I was so excited
about working that day that morning with
what did your uh what did your parents
do what did your dad do Mom
do my mom was a substitute teacher at
the school okay that we went to school
at what was that like for me I didn't it
was weird but it was weird for me and my
brother for me I would stay in the
classroom and watch the high school high
school okay uh and but we were
interesting this is what made I think
and this really made our high school
what high school by the way Spring Brook
okay so we we started was a when we
started the school
was
sorry nice sound listen as long as
you're healthy it is I am no it's really
it just pisses me off cuz I just got up
but we won't even go into that that test
test 47 so um 7th 8th and 9th we started
school the school starts as a junior
high next year it's 8th 9th and 10th
next year it's 9th 10th 11th so as a
seventh grader we spent literally uh we
went from 7th to 12th together so it
created a a really you know it you were
all by the time you in 10th Grade you
would run out of people that the people
could who could be beaten up and people
who were going to beat you up that was
so we'd already kind of gotten through
so we kind of were a pretty good group
together and uh my my mother would come
in to teach I would watch her my brother
was like [__] you I'm not sitting in
that class while she's up there she
would go he would skip the class he
would oh yeah he said I'm not dealing
with that your mother and and and that's
how smart he was cuz I'm I'm like I
better show up I would have been too I
like I'm better fing be in this yeah but
the second the second born is watching
is nothing's going to happen you know
she you know it's [__] and so he she
uh she was there and she was really and
what made it easy to be is she was so
fast at nailing kids that there was no
[__] there was no like oh we got
your mother today it was you wouldn't
believe what your mother just said in
this class she was and the the one the
the the big one was uh uh this kid said
kid said why have to learn this or
something about geography or whatever
you she she goes here's why um you know
that seers down in White Oak um you know
the gas station there well you know when
you graduate high school in a year and a
half or two I I just I just don't want
to be there when you're pumping my gas
your mom was that's your job and I have
to Here
China it's exactly
it you you better [__] that's why
you're that's why you're learning that's
how you should
teach not because you need to be
culturally appropriate or or informed or
education you don't want to be pump so
you're not down there pumping my pumping
gas and then dealing with me because all
I'm going to tell you as I told you you
don't want to hear a while you're
[__] pumping it and so that was my
mother my father was uh he worked he my
father the one of the great things my
father did you'll get a kick out of this
was that he um he lived in New York City
uh and he went to school now this is New
York he goes 1936 maybe let's see 7 yeah
1936 or 37 he goes to school from New
York City to um the University of
Oklahoma wow in like 1937 so as a Jew so
as I said you know the possibly the
first Jew to cross the Border you'll
ever be in Oklahoma probably yeah and an
goes there and he um lives with the a
couple who are one of the guys going to
school and they're both you know Native
Americans I can't remember what tribe
they were in so your dad went there for
school for an education yeah he went
there for an education and and they had
a good mechanic he wanted to be a
mechanical engineer but so I said you
know that's really odd pop you know you
decide you're going to go all the way to
Oklahoma I said why'd you do that he
said and he was an only child and his
father had died when he was one so just
his mother but he had cousins and stuff
and so they had that family unit and he
said the reason I went out there is he
said I wanted to be as far away as I
could be from my mother and still be in
the United
States and that was Oklahoma Oklahoma
and he was the guy who would drive to
Texas to get the liquor cuz Oklahoma was
a driver State the whole state back then
was H yeah oh wow as far as I know I
mean that was I remember Mary I mean
[__] even as I don't know if it still is
or not but it was uh Carol County where
we were was dry on Sundays but you could
go to like Howard County or just a
different County and get it like within
the same state which I always never
understood that [__] yeah but I
didn't know the whole state was Dr I
think it was you know sense and then um
so and he became a a mechanical engineer
and uh and and then it when he was in
his early 60s we were in the Vietnam War
my mother is uh yelling about the you
she's constantly yelling about the war
they're not going this is disgusting I
you know my father says uh you've done
no research on this you don't know if
the war is legitimate or not they they
based it on the Gulf of tonan resolution
uh and that's based on the the Geneva
accords I'm going to read the Geneva
accords and find out if we should be
there and I'm sitting there going who
who what in retrospect no one read the
Geneva chords except my father so not
even the president I don't think any of
them did somebody said that's what we're
going to tell them yeah it's about 70
pages of this stuff I mean I looked at
it you can barely and he read the whole
thing and closes the book and he said uh
there is absolutely on the basis of this
of what I just read there's we have no
moral reason to be in that country okay
this is [__] and uh but he at this
point was he was making seam mines which
uh that was what he designed and what
are they blowing up they were you know
it's all your it's all like Defending
Your Harbor so that was the reason he
never felt like it was a defensive
weapon so he never felt any guilt about
making a defensive so we're not they're
not using it to attack they're using it
to defend so it's a perimeter thing sort
of if you enter in this way audios yeah
you know you come fair enough right fair
enough don't start won't be none yeah
exactly but you just set it up too
because what however what happened was
is then within a six months of my father
reading this for a year um we mine Hong
Harbor the around we M the area around
we did see I don't know that we did and
we mined it and we put seam mines there
and now we're using my father's weapon
as a offensive weapon and he goes that's
it I'm out I'm not going to I'm I'm not
be a part of this anymore so how'd he
stop he quit that job he he retired damn
did he really good for him he retired
and uh and unbelievably began um doing
uh uh stained glass Apprentice to a guy
who does stained glass but did all of
these kind of wonderful stained glass
pieces and then began to take courses at
Montgomery College okay Montgomery
Junior College I played them in soccer I
just saw I was very
excited the coach is a fan sent
me you're a player forever I know that
was terrific that was very nice I was
good I was all Jo a cville man yeah we
played mcgomery I remember mcgomery
County yeah so that was that's so he uh
he had uh he started doing that and then
he started taking painting and then he
became then he painted and I've got like
130 of his paintings oh wow so your dad
just one of those creative talented
super smart people well it was kind of
remarkable because he could he
I think it's what he wanted to do you
know you see I think in part you know
the the generations that we came that we
came from you know basically you kind of
go I'm going to do what I want to do I'm
not doing I'm not buying this I say this
all the time we as men are different
than our fathers and my grandfather
fought in World War II my father's in
Vietnam and we're like I want to act and
they're like what do you [__] talk I
want to paint and dance like what are
you [__] talking about okay yeah
definitely a different breed but my
father really was like he had that in
him but it was a total example of
committing to it was like I'm not doing
this anymore I'm going to do this and
what a difference from that to Stained
Glass and painting and art yeah wow I
mean he ended up doing what he wanted to
do and then he and then another one of
the great lines I've ever heard anyone
say cuz it was cuz really he he made me
realize you that that you you you do
what it is you want to do you stay true
to yourself and the fact that there are
all of those people during the Vietnam
more that I you know I'm like I'm going
to lead for this I'm going to do that my
father is somebody who really gave up
something to you know and people did do
that but my father was one of them and
it's right in front of my face and it's
a huge lesson and uh he uh he becomes so
they it's he really he and he at the age
of 83 he decides that he's he's he stops
painting 83 84 go what what what's the
matter and I've never heard this from
anybody he said you know I ran out of
ideas I said what he said I did all the
idea I can't he painted everything that
was in there yeah he did about he did I
did he painted about 200 200 paintings
all told and you ever think you'll hit
the limit where you're like I don't know
I think I've talked about everything I
want to talk about a time I feel that
now you I do feel that I mean that but
what I feel is uh it's like that thing
of um I've done 12,000 jokes the
difference between a Democrat and a
republican okay you didn't hear the
first
11,999 I can't come up with another one
that's going to be funnier than the ones
I did and apparently you're still going
to continue these two parties even
though I've tried to point now what's
[__] these parties continue to be we
you know see it today with uh schmucky
the clown you know McCarthy they get
schmucky and then Gates and you watch
these guys and it is like out of a clown
car and so you kind of go um we've got
to really uh we've got to what's the
next joke I haven't sometime I'm walking
up I I haven't got the next joke they
are already telling the jokes yeah
they're are they're crushing it yeah
yeah I also I just think like I'm not a
political person uh and I often wonder I
don't know when it's going to happens
it'll be when this generation's in their
what 20s 30s but soon very soon there
will be a generation of politicians
who've existed with social media being
in their life from day one unlike us
where it came in for me and my early mid
20s uh this is going back to their
parents putting [__] up mhm and I think
you got to be crazy to get into anything
anymore with a history online cuz what
if your dad was a [__] Nazi yeah you
know what I mean and he's got a picture
of you with a [__] AK and you and you
know this [__] and then you're like I
didn't want to be in that picture you
know what I mean so I just think and
then thank God some of the dumb [__] I
did said whatever in high school or when
I was just some you know dumb piece of
[__] uh isn't on camera somewhere and
out there so I just I just feel like
politics it's already so so different
but I feel like it's going to get way
different in the sense that it won't be
what can this person do to help us it
will be how can we smear that person and
bring them down yeah because there it's
going to be there for everybody and it's
just going to be smear campaign smear
campaign it's never going to be hey this
person Lewis Black is here to do this
for you it's like Lewis Black's a piece
of [__] and look at these videos you
know and but I think the other when um
this is this is The Lunatic part of me
speaking but I also feel because I have
this I always have this faith in uh that
gener the Next Generation and uh for all
people yell about what they do they that
they will kind of go watch like my
brother are watching this and going um
we're not doing this [__] anymore what
we're going to do is figure out how to
work together and get these things done
I hope so and I believe that's what's
going to happen because I think they you
know each we I think my generation uh
failed in a massive amount of ways but
at least
initially uh in their 20s really tried
to figure out another path and you know
so we start Earth Day we do I said but
Earth Day I said the only
reason the only reason we started Earth
Day it it looks good on paper but really
all we were doing was we were doing so
many drugs we had to have one day that
would remind us what planet we were
living on
so but but we we ended up we we kind of
like I I feel like we kind of put these
little you know we did you know we
believed in this we believed in that
then we didn't follow through but it was
all on the table and then now really 40
50 years later 50 years later boom that
group is already starting to go you know
I'm gonna you got this kid who W in
Florida they I think you're going to see
a different I hope so I mean I well you
see it somebody just recently R you know
you kind of go you know uh a single
mother of five who won an an election
you kind of go there are people coming
out of the woodwork who are going
enough's
enough so we'll see I hope you're right
well so do I because I don't want to do
this for a living
no I uh I also feel like and I don't
know if it'll be my daughter's
generation or her kids but I do feel
like there will be a generation of
people that push back on social media
and be like we're not doing this
[__] I don't [__] that I don't want
to be on there and I I also think about
anonymity too where my daughter never if
she all of a sudden becomes 20 and was
like I don't want to be on social media
I never wanted to be but you guys put me
on it you know I've taken that I've put
her on Instagram a picture of me and her
our first Oreo game [__] like that yeah
she may not ever wanted to be on there
you know so and a kid she's going to be
nine next week so you know I think about
a lot of that stuff there's always push
back from something that everyone loves
that usually later on someone's like
yeah well [__] that thing you all love
yeah you know so we'll see well I think
we're going to get through that I think
um people get fed up with it I mean
people my my generation is like this
with it oh look we created this I don't
know uh what do you mean I'm trying to
get
a I I can't get Google I can't get
Google how you get Google you know and
and you watch kids watch me do it like
and I go stop it I'm like it's like
watching an ape you know trying to to
use digit for digits they're digits for
the first time so but I do think that
that that what happens is they're way
down the road with it and then there's
going to be the road where they I've
talked about this from time to time that
you know this we are basically you you
take this this is it's taking part of
your brain is here now you go you don't
go oh who played for the Ravens in
whatever year you kind of go [__] I
can't okay and then you look them up and
you you know where the the movie I can't
who the hell I can't remember movie
actors and I used to be really I mean
it's what I [__] was involved in that
business for a long time I've been
involved in this thing and I can't I was
like you know the movie with the guy you
know the guy and so so you what happens
I think is is that so we the first step
is is that we took our brain and I put
it in my pocket so I'm Lally carrying my
brain around next to my nuts that's what
I'm
doing see I got to reach in to to
scratch my balls and for a long time
that was doing all the thinking early on
too yeah and it was I want to ask you
this where does your so your dad was in
well so worked for the military so to
speak but not serving yeah the defense
department did he serve as was he okay
so like my brother works for the Army
but he's a scientist yeah that's it it
was the same thing
oh is he an a [__] yeah I know aine a
stop on the on the on the train from
Baltimore New York out there by cow's
baseball fields yeah where does your
love for government politics where does
that come from I have no love for it
what I don't know I don't know where you
got that where's your love the hate it
come from it comes because I know we're
better was your family a political
family were your mom and dad into
politics and things like that yeah they
and um the the neighborhood around it
was like the you are right outside of DC
right that that had a huge effect um or
neighbors Senators well we had a
neighbor down the road when I went to
high school his one of the guys his his
dad was a was you know big in politics
he was he I I think he he ran a few
times I I went out I mean I left I I got
out of politics because I was involved
with it so I mean I went out and helped
get a a judge elected and I'm the guy
who br brought the you know the boxes of
chicken and chicken salad or whatever
and hand them out and he makes a speech
and uh and all of that and I did that
for a while and but it was like uh and
and it was a different time because the
people like at that point um the the
Charles mcmas was a was a senator from
Maryland really great you know
Republican so I tell my mother you know
I'm voting voted for him and my mother's
like you can't but I said he's as good
as the other guy and if not so better
and they basically are off by two or
three degrees I said he's really good
and he speaks better so stop it get a
grip uh so I mean I kind of it was but
she she would run around you know League
of Women Voters she would try to get
people out to vote it was not a and it
was never a question of getting
Democrats out to voter rep was get
everybody and then my next door neighbor
was a Democratic leader so all of that I
was a wash in that stuff okay and then
uh and that but then you started
watching it all and dismantling it piece
by piece then I started to just this is
psychotic this is crazy you people are
nuts um what always one of the first
things that got to me was every year in
the Washington Post uh there would be
the picture of uh the capital and then
kind of an overshot and behind the
capital were the worst slums in the
world MH some of the worst slums in the
United States and and every year I'd
look at that and go okay how that was
the that was to me the end of like you
guys are looking out the window you can
see it and you're doing nothing
nothing so this is what I want to ask
because I know we got to get you out of
here um couple things did you or were
you able to at least have any real
meaningful conversations with your
parents before they passed is there
anything that stands out talking to and
and who who was more sorry uh that's
okay who was more sort of with it were
both of them still there mentally could
you have a conversation I know your mom
was the last three years was already
making you know took credit for the
career and stuff but were does anything
that stands out the with my father was
literally was it just kind of went
slowly and they both died in their sleep
of natural causes is that right it's
crazy God damn they live all that way
and it wasn't cancer or anything that
ultimately took them out or heart it was
just never woke up never woke up and
who's calling you to tell you my father
had you know his heart was slowing down
and it was but basically you know he's
101 I mean you know you kind of go how
many times I mean anytime that phone
rings I'm waiting to he
these I got two calls
com it's you know it's so that my father
and I didn't really have but of that
conversation um you know I could say I
could say goodbye and I could we uh we
had some we had moments that along the
way uh where you know it was um you know
where he was he was glad I made the
choice to do what I do he got it was
obvious he didn't have to say anything
it was obvious he got a big kick out of
what I was doing because he was he's the
one who got me into theater watching we
went to plays together and uh and so
then all of a sudden I was writing plays
that's really where I started and uh so
he was big on that and they'd come to
anything I wrote and my my mother was
still like well if you're not going to
be a doctor uh and you're not going to
marry a doctor you ought to just you
know get into health
insurance like come on you know I'm a
playright mom but so they were you know
and then but my mother and I my mother
was really her level of sarcasm was such
that she couldn't it was you know there
was always you know you never got it
straight but before about two weeks
before she passed we actually had uh
that moment did you yeah you know and
what was and this I've never really
talked about much except with close
friends is that uh we I realized my
mother and I had never really looked in
each other's eyes that's
interesting and what made you think that
you like caught our gaze and you thought
that we sat we because when I said
goodbye you know basically we there was
that moment and I'm holding her hand and
she's lying in bed and we just were
staring at each other for I'd say 30
seconds to a minute just quiet just
quiet and that was a life changer cuz I
feel like you know thank
you yeah we're moving on yeah so thanks
for making me nearly cry okay this is
not okay I don't come to LA to cry
[__] maybe you telling me yeah yeah I
want to get down and dig a little though
man that's nice cuz I want to know stuff
like that I it's I really do want to
know things like that if people get that
moment and and you look you said it 30
seconds of Silence there was more said
there than 104 [__] year well not you
know what I mean 104 years that could
ever be said using this tool right here
so that's that's powerful and then I did
ask if here's the here's the to that
this is the setup now so so I'm sitting
with my mother in we in Vegas I believe
it's either Vegas or uh or um out in uh
uh in in Atlantic City and it's me my
father my mother and a couple of others
and I turned to my I said you know I've
never asked you two this question I'm
65 I said mom was it your idea whose
idea was it to have children and she
pointed at my dad and said
is she says cuz if it was up to me I'd
never have
kids and I'm like oh if it was up to me
though Al my eyes are flipping yeah I
said you know I am just really glad you
waited till I was old enough and it
didn't to tell me it didn't disturb
me at that age it makes sense you know
65 okay I can handle this I thought you
were going to [__] hit me with you
and your mom staring at each other at
the Ed she said who are you or go get my
son you here to wipe my ass
like um dude thank you so much for doing
this this has been awesome oh this has
been great I really enjoyed it it's a
pleasure to meet you same I waited a
long time for you to sit in that chair
brother um we're going to get you out of
here but before we do please advice you
would give after everything we've talked
about advice you would give to
16-year-old Lewis
Black
wow
um uh
wow that's a that's a you know the
advice I give me was uh
um I was uh is um I've wrote a
book uh that is called Nothing s
and the the book really was written for
16y olds is that right well that's the
way I wrote it I mean I wrote it I
didn't I didn't directly but it's what I
wanted to tell them about like you've
been through it and I've been through it
when you kind of that that um you you
know that when you start out you're
going to going to make all these
mistakes along the way and there all of
these Places You'll Go um but if you can
figure out what you want to do uh it'll
help write the ship and and stop
worrying about what happens every day
but it took
me into my 40s to realize that and and I
I don't know what I I wish I told myself
what's in that book which is that um
that you know you know you you you you
CH you've chosen what you want to do
enjoy it and don't worry about it that's
great yeah that's great advice you know
D thank thank you very much plug promote
everything one more time please um I'll
be eating at your restaurant please get
me some free
food anybody who can send me bottles of
wine I'd be really happy um the uh we've
got I'll be doing shows on the road go
to lpl.com uh I do my uh my rcast you
can get from uh Spotify Apple wherever
uh if you go to the to ls.com you can
find out how to write a rant I'm I'm
reading these rants we're still getting
him out there uh if you want tickets to
the show I have a fan club it's the only
way to get around um ticket scalpers so
so I got the first 10 rows uh it's
called the [__] you fan club is it
really oh
yeah so so they and they and people
still [__] and you kind of go no you
know what do I pay for you've got to
have a human being okay and the human
being needs to be paid and it's $2 bucks
Which is less than Ticket Master and
you're not going to get diverted to
Stubhub you've been through it you know
the J I paid $1,500 for a ticket to see
me then you're a [__] idiot yeah and
so we set that up to to beat uh Ticket
Master and the rest of them and uh and
so you know come on out and uh and see
those shows and uh um and hopefully uh
if all gets cracking with the um I'm not
supposed to say this but I don't care if
all gets cracking with the um uh which I
think will happen with this this the
strike uh that um for sag and after that
uh I um I will be on The Daily Show for
4 days and inside out
too is uh we've gotten through a chunk
of it and uh we hope to get it out
depending on if the strike threw us back
but we were shooting for June or July
all right yeah very good young man thank
you it's been a pleasure for it's been
awesome thank you um as always Ryan
sikler Ryan sichler on all social media
we'll talk to you all next
[Music]
[Applause]
week